it's time to be 46. um
it's time for drew's news the weighted
blanket of news programs
and back at the desk with me is the
coziest co-pilot there is
i missed you all i miss you drew
i was in los angeles i was shooting i
was working um and
i got you a little present i did so i
went to my favorite crystal shop crystal
shrine in burbank showdown
and um i got you a present for season
two
yes this is a bumblebee jasper and you
know these stones have like
properties uh it's yellow like our logo
uh but it energizes you
it promotes honesty with yourself uh and
it helps
you achieve your dreams food i'm gonna
wear this for life
i love that it's the color of the show
and i love
crystals thank you rob welcome well this
show is your dream i know and you're
achieving it and so that is
uh that that marks it season two oh
rossie and you're in our signature happy
yellow as wow well girl i am home and
i'm back and there is much to talk about
drew
all right i know all this celebrating
and good news and yellow bright sunshiny
let's put on the black veils
here we go
i know we've both been distraught for
days
over this first story and i'm so glad
you're back
then we can properly really mourn this
variety says that reggae jean paige
shan't be returning to bridgette
we were all blindsided when lady
whistled down made the announcement
and someone who's totally on our side is
the legendary dionne warwick because she
posted a series of
hilarious tweets to demand the duke back
and even though they haven't worked just
yet we love her for them
when we got this news the first thing i
thought is this is why i have
abandonment issues
okay reggae i i was there for you reggae
and now you leave us i don't understand
it remember they came on the show
of course i just also hosted their
netflix emmy for your consideration
panel and did he mention it at all they
did not mention it no
no they did not but i will say this
this is not bad blood this is not drama
there is no scandal
what it is is that the books focus on
the other
bridgerton members and reggae jean paige
was
always set for one season and one season
only
maybe the each season's set on another
couple in bridgeton that's what the
books are but i was set on seeing more
of him
on that on season two so i will say the
casting for season two
is very exciting well that is true
exciting here
hollywood reporter says that actors
callum lynch shelly khan charithra
condren and rupert young are the latest
actors to join okay
hello gorgeous this is a beautiful
panel of extraordinary talent and
listen casting is key it brings people
into our world
and reggae jean paige has been around
but he really
popped from this series and now listen
there's bond talk with him and i think
we should keep the rumor
alive as well and start it here
i'd double that seven yeah you would i
would he'd be great i didn't hear the
double-oh-seven rumor
let's keep it alive and while your story
[Music]
ross
you